[Music]
melody is with us in dallas hi melody
welcome to the ramsey show hi guys hey
what's up
hi thank you so much for talking to me
sure how can we help
um so my husband and i um we have four
kids
we make about 50 grand a year and that's
just him i stay at home with the kids
um and we kind of got in over our heads
with our mortgage it's a little bit
tight um at the end of all of our bills
we have about less than 200 that's able
to go to savings
um and we're just wondering if we meet
sorry i'm nervous
we're just wondering um what we need to
do because we're
we're stuck here um and he kind of he's
open to working a second job
and um you know saving money until he
can
go back to school or something but he
doesn't want it to be like you know he
lives his life
working two jobs um so he's kind of like
i don't know what to do here if i should
try to work up in my company because he
likes his company
but he's just not making enough right
now
when you said i'm question i'm curious
about one part of your question melody
said we're stuck here
uh what do you mean by that i just want
to question that before we dig into all
this oh
yeah well we really like it here and
everything's so great about the area but
it's um
it's a new developed neighborhood and
they said that they
don't want anybody to sell for at least
a year from buying
so
i don't know i was wondering is that
even legal i don't know
no it's not that's what they told us
it's not there's not a
you don't have a need restriction that
prohibits you from selling for a year
that's just uh okay so how much is your
house how much is your house
um it's only at a thousand right now but
they said that because of um for tax
purposes it'll be
more like 14 next year
okay and then we have a mud taxes for
water
and it just adds up so fast yeah it was
14
we thought it would yeah yeah after
taxes and with four kids
yeah yeah realistically we have to have
a path
for his income to go up or you need to
sell the house one of the two
so you're asking right you're asking the
right questions
and it doesn't matter how much you like
it it's whether you can afford it and
you can't prosper with what you've got
there your house payment
is probably about 40 percent of your
take-home pay
and to your husband's what we figured at
this point yeah to your husband's point
melody he doesn't want to work two jobs
forever
as the path to keep this house that he
never gets to see
so that's not a good plan either you
know what i mean like short term if that
could change something that's fine
but not long term let me direct you to
kencoleman.com
ken is our ramsey personality that
teaches people
um how to find what they're good at
what they love and what gives them
some passion and then
start and only then start asking the
questions what do i have to do to be one
of those
what do i have to do to get he calls it
get clear
on what you want to do and why you want
to do it what's your talent your passion
um what is it that that um you'd love
doing
and what you're good at um and
then from that you go okay i don't i
don't necessarily have that degree or i
don't have that certification or i would
need to go be an apprentice to do that
from there you say all right i've got to
get qualified
and then i've got to get connected those
are the first three
of his steps of his path
stages to getting the work the dream
job that you love so moving up inside of
his company might be the answer but only
if it's moving towards something that he
loves doing
and that he's good at and that he's
passionate about and he sees himself
jazzed on sunday morning on monday
morning
he's not there right now yeah so we need
to say okay
five years from today three years from
today two years from today
what could i be doing
if i could be doing anything i wanted to
do and i had all the necessary degrees
and there was nothing holding me back
what's my favorite thing in the world
and i could make eighty thousand dollars
a year
maybe okay start asking yourself that
and then you don't take something just
for money
for sure that's a bad idea but you also
don't take something just because it's
in front of you and you didn't see
anything else lately
which is how he got here yes he just
took a job
yeah yeah and that's what most people do
it's not a bad thing
but the good news is the house has kind
of given you the wake-up call
so i think you guys sit down together
with the kids in bed
and you do some soul-searching about
what he's going to do with his career
and is that then going to manifest
itself into more money
fast enough to keep our family from
being broke due to this house
and i think you i think when you run
those scenarios melody you start looking
at the numbers and go
what does he need to make in order for
you guys to stay in this house and feel
good about it and afford it
and then yeah you know and is that
possible with this track that he's on
but then you look at the other option it
may actually be both it may be changing
careers
and you still realize this isn't the
house we need to stay in
in this season and that's okay when you
start to lay out all the options you
have
change career second job sell the house
some combination of that
you just start to feel more in control
because you realize you're not painted
in a corner with two bad options
you have more options than you think so
just spend some time just like dave said
when the kids are down
where you could just lay out all the
options on the table and that will
immediately reduce your stress
because you can see all of the paths to
get you to where you want to go and then
you can make the best decision
does that make sense yeah for sure i
also did want to ask you if you thought
it would be realistic for me to try to
do something from home
having four kids they're five and under
be tough but it can be done it would it
would require you to give up
any time that you have by yourself right
now so it would be before they wake up
or after they go to bed
that would be when that would happen
realistically yeah
and so it's just i don't even know where
to start i don't have
any kind of yeah i tell you what we'll
send you a couple of things i'm going to
send you a copy of christy's book
business boutique
um which will help with your ideas of
what you m where you might start and i'm
gonna send you a copy of ken's book the
proximity principle
and i want your husband to get on ken
coleman.com tonight
because we need a track towards making
80 grand
and i don't care how what the track is
or if it's three months three years two
years
one year five years whatever i need a
track
if you're not gonna put that track in
place you need to put this house up for
sale